- [Instructor] In several
videos, we have touched
on the idea of separation of powers
between three branches of
government in the United States.
You have the legislative
branch that writes laws
and decides on the budget
for the government.
You have the executive branch
that runs the actual government.
And then you have the judicial branch
that decides on the
constitutionality of laws
and actions by the government
as well as interprets existing laws.
And connected to this idea
of separation of powers
where each of these branches
are somewhat independent
but not completely independent,
is that they all have checks
and balances on each other.
We've talked about in multiple videos,
the executive can veto a
law by the legislative,
the legislative can override that veto,
the legislative decides on the budget
that the executive has
to run the government,
the judicial branch decides
on constitutionality,
the executive branch decides
who is even going to become
a justice in the Supreme Court.
And so when you have
this separation of powers
and you have this checks and balances,
it provides multiple opportunities
to influence policy and
the actions of government.
And there's two ways that
you could view influence.
You could view it as a positive thing,
after all, it's government by the people,
the people are sovereign
so they should be able
to influence what the government does.
But sometimes, a cynical view of influence
is well, who gets to influence?
And is it really by the people
or are there other interests,
maybe driven by things like
money that have undue influence?
But just to get sense of
how folks can influence
or where there are points of influence is,
well first, what laws get passed?
or what gets funded?
That's decided in the budget.
Now, as an individual, as a citizen
you can write letters
to your congress person,
you can petition them,
you can call them up,
you can show up at a
town hall that they hold
in order to speak your voice.
But there's also interest groups.
Now interest groups could be
corporate interest groups,
they could be unions,
they could be professions,
and these interest groups will often times
also lobby congress in order to influence
what gets funded or the laws
that get passed or don't get passed.
And the word lobbying
really is just this idea
of trying to influence the government.
Now a major way, a
major point of influence
in the United States is
when there are elections.
Who actually gets elected.
And so you can imagine, there
could be direct support,
endorsement for different candidates,
money, especially with mass media,
becoming more and more important,
becomes a bigger and
bigger part of elections.
So you can donate at an individual level
or you often see now, and this
is a very controversial area
where there's heated
debates on to what degree
large donations can be made,
to what degree corporations
can influence elections,
but who gets elected is perhaps
the biggest lever on our government.
For example, even if your
main concern is judicial
and the judicial is the one branch
that is most immune from elections,
Supreme Court justices are not elected,
they are appointed by the president
with approval from the senate.
But if you did care who is
going to be in the judiciary,
well there, there would
be a strong motivation
to influence who is going to be president
and then even once they are president,
there might be some
influence, some lobbying,
on who they appoint to the judiciary.
If a law gets passed by congress,
there's still another outlet.
You could petition the
executive to veto that law.
So I'll leave you there.
The main takeaway from this is
that because of these checks and balances
and separation of powers,
there's multiple levers
of influence in the government
and I've just touched on a few on them.
An interesting thing to
always think about is
how much of our current
levers of influence,
especially as they exist today
in our modern government,
how much of this was
intended by the founders
of our country, the authors
of the Constitution,
and how much is based on things
that we could have never predicted?
They could've never predicted
the size of the country?
the influence of mass media?
They could've never perhaps predicted
the influence of money?
Who knows.
I will leave you with that question.